okay so this is gonna be part two
what we did in part one
was set up
the Tactical opening for aikido's
nagawaza
we explained
that
spinal displacement
it's the term it's just a turn
he's just defining it
a dog
looks like that that's a dog okay don't
freak out over the I'll use the spine I
use the one guy I use the spanking
God just get the word understand the
concept
so we picture his spine in space it was
said in the first video
where it is is occupying territory
spinal displacement
moves him and I stand there
simple
it is a tactic
common to a social violence
since people are killed by other people
all over the place
a socially
commonly with that tactic I would not
call it stupid
it works it works all the time
as I said the Gracies change the world
with it
if they didn't do that they would have
never got to the ground where they
specialize and others were ignorant
the military uses it all the time all
throughout history even Musashi talks
about it
it's only stupid
when you know how to get out of the way
that's not many people
and I would say
that's probably
less than one percent of modern aikidoka
aside from asocial violence
you can
frustrate people not using the tactic
into using the tactic and I explained
how that
by moving
in a particular pattern a spiral pattern
at the commencement of their intention
then they not being able to reach you
and behind you they're behind you on the
spiral pattern
will attempt to reach across
when they reach across
they're going to first be closed because
they're going to try to get as close as
they can
but they're also going to be out of body
alignment okay so as I showed yesterday
let's have this foot forward
here is where the proper body alignment
is for showmanucci
but the person attacking had this body
alignment
this creates openings
or as I showed you when he was kicking
it happened over here on the mat lift
your foot up he's throwing a front kick
but I was traveling this way
and he attempted to reach across but
momentum's going that way that is a
poorly executed kick but it's done out
of frustration
you can also frustrate somebody
who is attempting not to finally
displace
by coming in methodically
so for example in Judo because there's
no strikes you'll see people come in
methodically and grab different things
once you put the Strikes Back In you
can't do that anymore you he's going to
punch me in the face
you got to get past those strikes
so by making people pay for bridging too
slowly and cautiously
they will press on you and finally
displace
that's not a stupid thing a stupid thing
is walking in slowly to a guy that's
going to pugilistically kick your ass
or
if I have weapons on me and he knows it
he wants to suppress my ability to draw
the weapons again that's the smart thing
the methodical guy I'm gonna draw my
knife and now he's fighting a knife and
not just a guy who has a knife and a
sheath on his body
two different things
so
you there are ways you will face spinal
displacement in a social virus there's
ways you can generate it
and this creates the Tactical opening
for kihonawaza nagawaza
it does not mean it's the way you fight
we were just answering the question
where is the Tactical opening for
nagawaza it's in spinal displacement
at some point because fights are like
this
his Striker town
touch me
but not hit me those are different
things or I'm going to be able to touch
his strike
so in that one where we had the
showmanuchi and it was angled off
because I'm spiraling this way but his
momentum was going that way he starts to
turn towards me
he's behind me on the spiral but here's
where I touched it and that's where the
technique is
so a contact point is going to be made
but I don't make it
he makes it in his attempt to get me
then I use the contact point
so we're going to do a progression drill
towards that okay so we're not going to
go to strikes yet
but he's going to attempt
to grab me two hands one hand wherever
got it so let's see you do that good
getting grabbing anywhere anywhere any
kind of ground okay and I don't want to
stay there
let me ask you what am I going to do
I'm not going to stay there I'm gonna do
what
I'm going to start the spiraling
footwork when
at his intention that's too late
commencement of movement is too late so
here we go and I'm already moving
you're gonna see him have to reposition
and we're going to get a contact point
again go
[Music]
he's pressing
go so if I didn't move that was
legitimately worse
so what I want you to do if you get me
you're going to take me down whatever
you want
[Music]
foreign
this next drill
he is going to continue his attack on my
center it's going to continue attempting
that balance of action spinal
displacement okay so we'll go slow so
you can see boom he's going to keep
friends all he got me
not one time
we go
foreign
[Music]
I have to keep moving okay not just one
time
keep attacking
[Music]
foreign
at no point
could you go young with your response
you see it as if you can't okay
um
for those who don't understand he's
coming in and comes in again and I go
down
some of you failed here
that's why you failed because you went
Young on his yawn when he came in
the next lesson we want to pull out
is
I am not a shop putter
some of you are understanding the
imitencon
the way a shot putter understands it
so he's coming in and you're lying
[Music]
so we have to pull something else out
because this is going to get us his
striking remember it's a strike at some
point
we're going to have a contact Point that
he's going to make
in his striking
I use the contact point the question is
how not like a shot putter
I adhere to it okay so we'll go like
half speed so I can talk okay so he's
going and here is the adhesion
now
you see so when he counters it it's
still stuck
you think
so your I'll talk I'll point out a
reason you counter it to continue the
pressing and I'm going to use the
adhesion not the shot foot or admit 10
times so we're going boom
[Music]
foreign
he's still trying to press
not ever
letting himself go flying out
I'm making you do that
hey
[Music]
thank you
that's shot putter
don't don't run in the circle keep
cutting across to his Center Line
do you understand UK hi
[Music]
okay so what this last drill does
is
it's basically henka Mazda say he's
trying to counter the initial I.T
adhesion but you can't count you can't
this is why oh Sensei would say it's in
irrevincible you can't counter
what is not opposing you you cannot
counter what is you you see but in the
sense that when you're in myths and Ike
there's no you nor me
so there's nothing for you to counter
okay that's
the
the kind of mystical sleight of hat okay
so if you watch every time he comes in
and he counters and you go here you see
that you you race on him right this is
where prior to that you already had a
big huge eye
in the ice he say there is no I there is
no I said there's no you to protect
there's no hymn to stop okay so that's
going back to your answers this drill
would work on that because when you go
to striking
it's much faster
even closer okay
uh many aikidoka think it's further out
it's not it's closer striking is closer
than wrist straps okay for the simple
reason both are going to finally
displays but in one
here's my Target and in the other here's
my target so I have to penetrate deeper
do you guys see that so it's closer
making this
very I don't know what we're doing out
here okay especially him waiting there
and then I come in
anyway so then it moves last second move
last second
no this is not right
okay
so in this drill I got a guy that's
running at me grabbing wherever because
when they're striking and missing that
contact point is going to be wherever it
is it can't be the perfect elbow it's
whatever is touching me however it's
touching me okay so in this drill when I
look at I have to spinal displacement
but it's quite spontaneous with what I
do with my hands
and then he tries to initially yin to
the young spinal displacement but I
counter again his energy
you see and I keep pressing
giving him another opportunity
so I press
[Music]
knock knock you Melissa
so look how you're trying to go that way
right you're trying to go this way
but what did I do
yes
I'm still driving but I'm countering you
see
this requires you to release release
so we go contact he's carrying he's
hooking that head again
there you go
he hooks the head I gotta go with it
[Music]
if you go in then what
stripes are available
vertical
[Music]
thank you
strikes available
all right try it again
[Music]
don't pick
don't try to throw him
make him oh well try to get you then the
throw will be there
turn turn turn
tight on him
[Music]
better
thank you
because young young
press press
[Music]
counter counter counter
Yang Yang you went young you're gonna
have to sprawl
turn don't worry about throwing him make
him Miss
there you go turn again yes turn again
yes
today
turn Ronan turn
again
turn again yes
you gotta turn more
switch rolls
turn turn go see change direction turn
again
turn get ready he's gonna come back
there you go that's it
yes
there we go
you're fighting you're fighting you're
fighting turn turn turn
yo you went for the technique
turn first then the technique he'll
reach for you then that's your contact
point
[Music]
foreign
there you go
[Music]
all right
so let's slow it down again and let's
re-look back at the idea okay so he's
gonna come in he grabs that's where we
have contact so uh can you see camera
there it is here's one right here
here is the other one more on his wrist
even though he's holding my hand okay so
as you feel my feel me in your Center
okay so he's gonna go around that but
I'm gonna stick now here you feel it you
see
here it is right here
so for example don't adhere to me
block
that's now possible without the adhesion
but
when I get the adhesion he goes to
counter I'm not going to be caught off
guard you'll kind of stick to it you see
you stick to it alright so I need that
I also can't go long against his young
I also cannot brace against his yawn
and once I turn I'm looking for him he's
not going to keep running that way
he's gonna turn into me
so I look for that turn
you have two options
so we're here you're gonna turn into me
I can stay ahead of it in the back but I
have to stay in the back
so if I go if it turns towards me and I
stay here that's not it
he turns towards me and I stay in the
Box
that's 10 times
or
he turns as far as me and I go back the
other way
go turn this way turn this way
don't
chase the throat
follow the Union
so we go and here he comes around this
way he comes around again this way
the technique will reveal itself
but you have to understand
[Music]
the footwork and what it does
to his young aggression okay so I'll say
turn turn turn okay when do you think
you turn
at the level of what
intentions
if he's turning and you're there you're
late
got it you have to feel it you have to
Intuit it okay let's go
good who cares if he doesn't get you if
you don't throw him
there you go that's it
look for him to re-zero turn the other
way
and here not crab you brace there when
you chose the technique you chose the
technique then you went young then he
got you okay
[Music]
so it's very difficult to do without the
adhesion you're all external you got to
get stuck on him
on you
there he goes
different
no
you feel it
feel it
foreign
[Music]
you gotta get that it won't work without
you okay let's go
Okay so
in this drill what we've been doing is
there's more gu in it because it's hen
kawasa okay
and he's trying to counter my occasional
um let's pull out some things as we go
into part three on another day
um at no point
did I yawn on you to any great success
okay right and you if you let if you
yawn back on them they're gonna tie you
up they're gonna take you down you're
not getting nagawazo that's for sure
it doesn't necessarily mean you're out
of the fight but you're not getting lost
um
also at no point then
did I stop him
okay which would be a young young Clash
so if I was successful at no point as he
came in did his Center stop
see and then I did my technique
so I ask you
here
imagine you're against
coming in with that kind of bulls horn
bear hug
what would happen you stopped him and
tried to assuming
Yong Style
what yeah they just throw you just you
actually went into the bear hug or the
choke
Okay so
um that is the two most important
takeaways
4 part 3. you can't stop his Center okay
and you can't yawn back on his young
neither neither one works okay
um
and then you either have I key or you
don't we found that out
you can't do the same things without Ike
as someone with IQ you could be
successful but not as often not to the
same degree
okay that's just the fact that's why
he's been developed I.T is not some
magical psyops
where I'm trying to get in your mind
it's not sound body mechanics sound body
mechanics is sound body mechanics okay I
key what you want to understand it
is at its most concrete tangible level
is an adhesion
at the contact point
that adhesion is generated by principles
of the universe
when I match his yin yang value
the universe treats us as one not as two
and we adhere like a gravitational pull
happens and we get stuck and I move him
like that
when it comes to hand kawaza or Stripes
that are barely hitting me
I have to be able to stick at the
contact point
okay so that you're going to need uh but
the two main things from this experiment
are yawning him it's not going to work
for nagawaza and stopping him
is also not going to work okay will not
work so when we go to strikes I never
stop him and I never young him
for example Yoko manucci
[Music]
now
that's not how that technique works that
is
stopping him not going to work you don't
want to do that here
stopped him
now
correct
show me energy
stop him
now
okay we don't want to do that in
grabbing we definitely didn't want to do
it in pushing grabbing here we're not
going to do it at all in Striking okay
hi
thank you